in the eastern Ukraine town of seversk
collecting firewood is becoming a matter
of life and death for retiree Valentina
kazakova
it's a terrible situation she says how
could it be anything but terrible
her apartment building is destroyed she
and her husband have lived in the
basement since July with no power no
water and no gas
there's a lot of shelling noises she
says every time her heart freezes and
she waits foreign
mortar fire and widespread Devastation
and with Russian attacks disabling ever
more power grids and water
infrastructure energy providers are
using planned power cuts to avoid
overloads and allow repairs leaders in
regions enduring power blackouts
including Kiev are warning residents to
prepare for the worst with the onset of
winter later this month
key of Mayor Vitali Klitschko says in
the event of a total blackout residents
should consider moving to emergency
lodging with friends and family who live
elsewhere and have control of their
water and heating supply the Russian
effort to break the will of ukrainians
by depriving them of life's Essentials
is an age-old tactic used in many
previous conflicts a development that's
causing military analysts to re-evaluate
the Russian invasion yes this could lead
to cities going dark in Ukraine where we
can send generators we can allow Ukraine
to take back more territory this will
send a message to the Russian military
that this their situation is not
encouraging that Russia ultimately will
lose this conflict Brown calls the
Russian tactic energy terrorism he says
Canada and other allies need to step up
supplies and support to Ukraine to
ensure Vladimir Putin fails
Ross Lord Global News